hey what's up my name's samuel leeds and
in this video
i am going to be talking about my faith
now my christian faith
is very important to me and did you know
i am actually
a christian rock god according to joe
lysett from channel 4.
so is this entrepreneurial youtuber
friend of the stars and christian
rockguard now
in all seriousness is this going to be
about property not really
it is going to be about property
indirectly this is more about me
personally and the reason i
did this video is because my my
christian faith has been talked about
quite a lot
in the media i mean joe lycia was
literally playing my
uh my christian songs and kind of taking
the nick a little bit
[Music]
well that's one me over to satan and
there's been a few different references
nick tad from
property tribe said i was a
self-worshiping
self-centered christian i was thinking
christian no i'm just kidding
but but it's like why does my faith come
up so much
into you know these critics and
journalists and different peoples
you know what why do they focus on my
faith rather than just my
business it's kind of strange i mean
when joe lycen on his show i think it
was catherine ryan when she started
calling me ugly she was like people
trust him so much because he's
unattractive
so why do people find samuel so
believable catherine
oh well it might be because we're
hardwired to find unattractive people
trustworthy
i was just thinking how can 2020 how can
you get away with this
how can you like knock people's faith
and call people ugly
it's like listen man if you want to talk
about my business
and you want to critique it we can talk
and you can but i find it's kind of
really strange people do that
however i would also say maybe part of
the reason is because i do very much put
myself
out there as a christian and i'm very
i'm not a secret christian and to be
fair i was advised against this i have
had advisors
and people that really care about my
business that have said to me samuel
don't talk about your faith don't talk
about religion
don't talk about god you're gonna
alienate people
you're gonna have people criticize you
you're gonna lose business over it's
going to be damaging for the business
so i've had a lot of people say that to
me um
really surprisingly because has it
damaged the business and has it lost me
money i don't really know because
i can't do a split test and say well
this is what it was like when i did it
because i've always spoken openly about
my faith
some people even say the reason i talk
about
my faith and the reason i talk about
religion is because it's like a pr thing
and i'm trying to get
more money by doing it which is kind of
strange i can't really see how
that would work exactly but the truth is
i wanted to in this video to really talk
about
why i talk about religion sometimes
and disclaimer if you're not religious
or if you're of a different faith to
christianity
i love you absolutely loads and this is
not me sort of trying to
convert you or trying to be preachy
i'm only doing this video because a lot
of people ask questions about it
the media sometimes make fun of me a
little bit for being a christian
and i just wanted to really explain
where i'm coming from and also
why i feel the need to sometimes
do that and how it links to my because
my property business believe it or not
is absolutely intrinsically linked
to my faith so that's what i'm going to
be talking about in this video i'll be
going over the whole story
so if you're only interested in just how
to property videos
then maybe you won't find this video
super helpful so please don't
unsubscribe
because it's rare i do a video like this
just tune out and watch another video
but if you are interested a little bit
more in my life and in the story
and in how my faith has helped me so
much and also been
linked to my business i guess this video
is kind of
indirectly also going to be about
property and business so
let me take you right back to me as a
kid
me as a young boy listen i'm from a
christian family my parents
made me go to church growing up and i
never really
wanted to go to church for me it was a
religious boring thing to have to do
and it wasn't until i left school and
surprisingly when i left school
that was when i actually had a really
spiritual experience
and i became a christian and suddenly
i'd gone from being forced to go to
church when i didn't want to
to now working for my dad's company
and my dad was forcing me not to go to
church now
because he was making me work on the
family business on a sunday
so now i'm like okay so my dad forced me
to go to church but i didn't want to
now i want to go to church and my dad
won't let me because i'm going to have
to work this really sucks and my
strongest
reason for getting into property
was because i wanted to leave my dad's
business
and stop working my dad was an
entertainer so i was doing like
children's parties and magic shows and
stuff
as as 16. i only did it for three months
but i
left that business and got into property
to give me
freedom to go to church which is really
really crazy so
kind of the reason i got into property
in the first place was because i wanted
to go to church and pursue my faith
which is why it's kind of intrinsically
linked and
listen maybe if you as i say if you're
not a christian you might be able to
relate to this because you might want to
do something else maybe you're a muslim
and you want
more time and you want to get out of
your job because you want more time to
pray and go to the mosque
or maybe you're not religious at all but
you just want more time
to write poetry and that's your
spiritual side or you want to
write books or you want to travel or
maybe your religion is
football and you just want to play loads
of football but you haven't got the time
you want to do recreational things
because of your job well that was me
and the reason that i really desired to
get out of
having to have a job and having to be a
slave and work for money was because i
really wanted to pursue
um my church activity i wanted to go on
trips my church were organizing trips
there was a trip to pathoblanco spain
where where
volunteers were going out to work in a
drug rehab center
and it was it was a mission christian
based trip but also
offering practical help and support for
people in the drug rehab center i
thought i want to do that i want to go
so i quit working for my dad i went into
property
and you probably know the story of my
property journey because i talk i've
talked about that
quite a lot but if you haven't there'll
be a card just here where you can watch
my whole story
of how i got into property and that's
how it started so as a teenager i
started going on trips i went to
um as 18 years old i went to africa i
spent a month in zambia i was working in
orphanages i was at chengallo
christian school working in a school and
i was really gripped and i wanted to
dedicate my life to
the cause of helping people loving god
loving people
and that's kind of how it all started
now the interesting thing is whenever
i'd go on a trip but whenever i start
getting involved
i did it from a place of wanting to help
but there was also i guess a selfish
part of me that just really enjoyed
doing it i like traveling i liked the
feeling of helping people
when i went to africa i legitimately
went because i wanted to help people
people i thought that it's not right
that there's people that have got
like very very very little and we're so
fortunate
in in many parts of the western world
but then actually when i went out
whenever i'd
help people um i'd always find that
i went to make an impact but then i
ended up being impacted even more myself
probably than they were so it was like a
real uh
spiritual thing where i found myself
growing i
found myself happier when you look
inwardly constantly i think it makes you
miserable but when you look outwardly at
how you can help
others and when you when you try and
help people and when you look outwardly
to god
i just find i'm a happier person and
more fulfilled and of course
to help people to dig wells and bring
clean water and to
provide food it needs money because
money
makes things happen and this is why i
really believe money is not good or bad
it's just at all it depends whose hands
it's in
so a lot of people that i was with in my
church were thunderizing
and i found that some people that really
set out to go and do good projects and
good things
ended up becoming full-time fundraisers
and i thought i don't really want to do
that
i'd rather fund it myself and have a
business that makes money
and be able to just fund the works that
i do myself so that was why my property
business worked really well hand in hand
my family my mom and her new husband
tim were very very involved with the
church also we used to go out we used to
give free pizzas to people
um that were we used to go out to the uh
clubs
in warsaw town center early hours of the
morning and there's always people that
are really destitute or people have been
left by their friends or
people that have got really drunk and
can't get home or spent everything
or women that have are just in a really
bad place and we used to just give them
free pizza
from domino's we hooked up with domino's
give them pizza and then we just have
conversations listen to people hear
their stories
and it was just something that i really
enjoyed doing and my church were
involved with
and i wanted to grow my property
business alongside
all this works now when i was 20 that
was when i had quite a decent property
portfolio
and some of my church actually started
saying to me samuel you shouldn't have
too many houses and it was this real
kind of poverty mindset
which is why i ended up writing this
book which is called do the possible
watch god do the impossible i wrote this
a little bit later while i was just
finishing bible college but
that's another story so 20 years old i'm
at a point now where i'm financially
independent i've got a nice
little portfolio which which is enabling
me to live
i want i've got these few trips i'm
involved in my church and some
activities
so me and my family me my mom my sister
my stepdad tim
we moved to warsaw where we already
lived in war so we've been peso which is
kind of like a nice part of warsaw
or as far as warsaw goes and then we
moved to a really rough part of warsaw
and we moved into a council estate
called limou where there's lots of
gypsies and rough kids
and we bought a minibus and we would do
trips with these kids
and really you know there were some of
them were in a really bad place just
emotionally
and unstable so we would uh just work
with them and
give them treats the kind of thing that
kids just should have you know take them
to trips to waterworld
and auckland towers um and it was we're
quite well known in
in the estate of lima i just signed up
for barber college i did bible college
with my mom we were like
really really close and still are today
so i spent three years at bible college
studying theology
and while i was at bible college i was
also continuing to grow my property
portfolio but
very much in the background and i was
also studying personal development so i
was heavily continuing to study jim rohn
i was going to business conferences
while at full-time bible college
the barber college was an ex-bbi bible
college which was known as
new college and the principal was robert
pickles dr reverend robert pickles who's
just a fabulous guy and i do stay in
touch
loosely with him today very very very
small college
and uh while i was going to these
different business conferences at the
same time though
i remember i was at this big business
conference and there was about
500 people in the audience it was a
three-day
business program and the speaker bear in
mind
i'm a business person and i'm also a
bible college studying theology and
studying the bible
the the speaker was saying stuff while
he was teaching business
that was literally straight out of the
bible okay it was
like for instance as a man thinks so he
is
and he was he was saying stuff like this
and i'm thinking that's in the bible
but he didn't credit the bible he didn't
reference the bible
and i'm thinking this is kind of strange
and a lot of the teachings i realized
that a lot of the stuff
well i almost nicked out of the bible
now the really interesting thing was
there was
christians at the event that were saying
oh this sounds a little bit worldly and
a bit
uh sinful and i remember thinking at the
time there seems to be a real separation
between religion and christianity and
faith and just being a good person
a generous person this idea there seems
to be like a contradiction with business
and making money and i thought there
really doesn't have to be
and i remember thinking at the time i
wonder if the trainer
who's teaching and everyone there 500
people who are listening to him for
three days
taking notes listening to him i wonder
if he's a christian
you know but and i was waiting for him
to to mention or to say story and he
never
did and i found out after the event
because i spoke to him briefly that he
actually
is a christian i thought why would he as
someone who
is a christian who's had their life
transformed by god
who's very very passionate about their
faith and it really helps them as a
person
why would they not just take the
opportunity to just mention that
you know just mention that to at least
maybe let some people just sort of think
not to try and preach or to try and
convert anybody i thought that's a real
shame
and you know again if you're not a
spiritual person or a religious person
you might think now i'm being a bit
cuckoo
but what i can describe happened at that
time
was i almost felt a a message in my
heart
from from god i believe i believe it was
a message from god
almost tell me when you're on stage
now by the way at the time i'm only like
18 years old i never intended to be on
stage it's just this
this this feeling of don't judge him
he's doing him
he's doing his thing don't be like upset
with him for not saying that he's a
christian when he's a christian like
don't judge him but when you're on stage
samuel
um you can you can take the opportunity
just to mention that you're a christian
and not to be ashamed of your faith and
i just
i just remembered that feeling and i
didn't think about that for many years
later but all the way through bible
college
when i was learning about theology and
being a christian
and the bible like to literally learn to
read and write in ancient greek and
hebrew i can't say
i ever mastered it but but i was kind of
getting there and i was studying that
and i was also practicing my business
growing my business studying i i it
became more and more clear that actually
it's not about choosing do you want to
serve god or do you want to serve money
it's about
actually i want to love people and i
want to love god and i want to do that
through money as a tool
and i wrote a article um which turned
into almost like my dissertation
actually i did a whole piece and i
turned that then kind of into a book
which is this book and this book really
helped me
it really it really released me from the
guilt of earning money
and it really showed me that actually
you can be a
capitalist but also have compassion be
it to be a
compassionate capitalist and the more
money you have the more people you can
help and actually
even even growing a big business you've
got to help people to grow big business
because you've got to have a product or
service that people want
so this book was really good and i know
it's really good because it sold
thousands of copies across the world
and after i published this on amazon i
started getting people reach out to me
and saying
you know this really helped me this
really opened up my eyes and through
bible college and after i wrote this
book
i launched a christian business network
now i launched this at the back end of
2013
we had our very first official meeting
in 2014 january
and it was called training kings you
can't serve god
and woman but you can serve
god through money the kingdom is in our
hearts
and training kings was something where i
was i had my own business i was making
money
that's all good but training kings was a
network
where i wanted to teach people and
inspire and equip people
that had good hearts that were good
people and it was it was set up for
christians because a lot of christians
didn't understand money
and they didn't understand the
difference between being a good person a
generous person and actually making
money so i set it up initially for
christians training kings now it wasn't
exclusive we never
said you have to be a christian but it
was set up for people
generally within churches but we did
have muslims we had sikhs we had
jews we had all kinds of we had people
that were completely
atheists that would come along because
they believed in the general cause of of
what we were doing
now training kings really took off and i
ended up employing people
we had 14 different branches across
across the country
and that ran for five years and from
training kings what i found was a lot of
people started saying to me you know can
you teach me about property specifically
and that's a long story but that's when
i then set up in 2016. i set up my
property training company but all
through this period
of running training kings of speaking at
churches
um even even amanda okay when i first
met my wife we met at a christian church
and her dad was quite a traditional
zimbabwean guy he actually lived in
zimbabwe at the time so there was
a real culture difference me being from
england me being
white my wife being black being from
zimbabwe there was some culture
differences
and you know amanda's dad was a little
bit unsure
but it was actually the fact that when i
said to him listen you know we are one
in
christ and that i think it was really
that that brought real unity and a sense
of understanding
me and my wife we started going to
mosaic church in coventry
and pastor gary spicer and pastor helen
spicer
really kind of mentored us and they
still do today i'd still say my
my spiritual home is mosaic church and
coventry despite attending
one more local to my home now in
buckinghamshire but that's my story of
my faith so
when i started then doing property
training events
it's kind of no surprise that i would
say to people i would just mention that
i'm a christian
and my faith would come out a little bit
now again as i say not in a preachy way
when i'm running
property training i'm there to teach
people about property but
it's no surprise that sometimes it
spills out or people can see or i might
say your thing or part of my story
and as my property training really grew
and suddenly when i'm like having a
thousand people or week
crash courses there were some people
that maybe
a few people that might have been a
little bit ticked off but not many you
know very very very few i think it's
more the media
kind of taking the mickey out of it
because the way that i mention my faith
is in my opinion is very unjudgmental
and i think what people don't like is
people don't like it when you judge them
but that's the case
that's not just if you're a christian
that's if you're a vegan or if you're
whatever you believe in your lifestyle
choices the problem happens when you
start judging people
but i don't believe in that and even
jesus who's my ultimate lord my savior
my example
he didn't judge people you know he
didn't go around judging people and that
he he just sat with people loved people
so that's really my example and really
what i want to do
my mom which i actually published for
her has just
written a book this is my mom's first
book called one life make it count
this is a really good book and if you
want to know more about
what i believe i mean hey this is what
my mama taught me growing up so this is
not it is a christian book but it's more
about living and
you know i'd recommend reading this book
i really would i don't know if me being
a christian
if if if that makes my business more
successful or less successful many
people
taught me not to because it would be
less but whether it does or whether it
doesn't if my business suddenly starts
really hurting
because of my faith i'm not really that
bothered
because i'm just i'm just gonna continue
being true to me if it flourishes
because of it then great
so i don't know i don't care for me my
my christian faith my belief in jesus my
belief in god
it it's for me it's just been not only
something that's got me started in
business
and a mission for me but it's just been
something that really just keeps me
going keeps me focused
i've had a lot of bad stuff happen i've
had serious accidents i've had
near-death experiences while i've had
car crashes
i've had people stab me in the back i've
had lonely times
but my it's my faith in god that just
gives me
strength to keep going and also purpose
to always look forward
so that's kind of me that's my story if
you want to know more about that side of
things as i say my mama wrote this book
and it is really good i love my mom so
much so you can get this on amazon this
is my book
nothing compared to this book but this
is still kind of good and uh
yeah thanks for watching thanks for just
letting me be honest
don't subscribe if you want to see more
videos like this because i'm not going
to talk about my faith in christianity
much on youtube
but do subscribe if you want to learn
about property because we've got some
really cool property content videos
coming up so subscribe
smash the like button drop a nice
comment below
and if you want to watch the video of my
whole life story of
on a business level then you can watch
this video right here
there we go check it out and if you want
to see stories of other people
that have become successful in property
as a result of my training you can see a
load of stories right here but please do
subscribe down here and i'll see you
next time